the white house not denying a report
that the biden administration has been
secretly flying thousands of
unaccompanied migrant children from
texas to the new york city area the new
york post is calling it biden's secret
flight sounds clever
and it's reporting that 2 000 children
have been flown from our southern border
and sent to drop-off points in new
jersey new york and connecticut this
seems like a good story for peter ducey
to ask the white house about
why is the administration flying
thousands of migrants from the border to
florida and new york in the middle of
the night
uh well i'm not sure that it's in the
middle of the night but let me tell you
what's happening here um it is our 4 29
a.m well very early in the morning here
we are talking about early flights
earlier than you might like to take a
flight so in recent weeks uh
unaccompanied children pass through the
westchester airport which i think is
what you're referring to and route to
their final destination to be unified
with their parents or vetted sponsors
and since democrats love fairness and
equity ted cruz has an idea on where to
put the massive influx of migrants
their entire political strategy is based
on secrecy what what is happening at our
southern border is an absolute tragedy
i've introduced legislation today in the
senate it's called the stop the surge
act well what my bill does is it
designates new ports of entry so rich
democrats can be sitting there and
suddenly see 10 20 30 50 000 illegal
immigrants like we're seeing in texas on
a daily basis and i can just envision
them in nantucket sipping a martini
going oh goodness they want to come to
our clubs they would be horrified
you know uh uh dana that was from
america's newsroom it's a show great job
yeah okay
this seems like something that we cooked
up which means it's good
right the port of entry at martha's
vineyard i swear one of us has probably
said this but it's actually uh it's very
clever because obviously it's it's made
the news but also it's kind of
legitimately correct yeah and and he
makes a point he made the point this
morning that and we've been saying this
too president biden never gone to the
border kamala harris is in charge of the
border doesn't go and and when you let's
say that there's a natural disaster
what's one of the first things a
president does goes down surveys the
damage sees what is going on so that
when he or she eventually gets back they
can say okay we need to do the emergency
declaration this is what they're going
to need and i'm going to make sure you
make sure that they get everything that
they need they don't they just ignore
this and what's interesting is president
trump had taken all this grief right for
all the things all the things on
immigration and all president biden had
to do was maintain the status quo but
instead they did a twitter poll
basically and made policy based on that
and what you end up having is it's
poisoned the well against the
need and demand for legal immigration
people who are here waiting in line
trying to get it done legally and it
just has completely made it the issue
toxic the other thing is because of the
flores agreement stick with me the
children cannot be held unaccompanied
minors cannot be held for longer than 30
days so customs and border patrol has to
send them somewhere they give them to
health and human services and that
department takes off you'll be talking
about pete buda judge and where he's
been
where in the world is secretary becerra
it's like is he in the witness
protection program yeah they're all
missing they're all on milk cartons
it's amazing harold
why doesn't the democrats actually take
cruz at his suggestion or the bill
because share the responsibilities i
mean
i think that would make a lot of people
happy
republicans happy if if it looked like
the non-what he called the non-border
privileged shares some of the uh
responsibility so you would presumably
still have to put people on a plane to
take them to these places so we would
have the issue we had uh with this and
they went to westchester which is i'm
sure the people in and around those
communities in new canaan and darien and
greenwich probably would not want the
same thing that ted cruz is trying to
suggest there look
can you imagine
40 years ago 30 years ago
then a sitting united states senator
joking like senator cruz did there i
think senator cruz is a serious guy he's
a smart guy he's a well-educated guy but
let's get serious we have a problem at
the border if you want to force
democrats and shame democrats shame them
with policy i've said on the show before
i've laid out what i think is a
predicate i i've laid out that i think i
hate to say this on a day where
secretary york has wished him the best
and my prayers are with him and his
families he's dealing with covert 19
positive tests but we've got to get
we've got to get a serious person there
who can manage this crisis and who's
willing to negotiate with republicans
and as much as this may get some nice
headlines here for senator cruz and we
get a nice chuckle from it you still
have to fly people to martha's vineyard
into the hamptons and to all the other
places
but i think but i think his larger point
is the right one we've got to
incentivize democrats to want to be uh
more serious about this and it seems
like we may need to have republicans he
went on to say that he knows that the
democrats aren't going to move it
forward he is making a point and
sometimes that's why you do some stuff
exactly exactly you know katie why
do you think these flights were at night
who were they hiding from not i mean
they're not hiding from cnn because
they're not covering it they did those
flights because of fox that's my theory
maybe they did maybe they got that idea
from you greg because you're so
brilliant oh thank you but on the issue
of policy i will point out that that
senator lindsey graham and i can't
remember that which democratic senator
actually
offered up the suggestion that jay
johnson who's the former dhs secretary
under obama come in and manage the
border crisis because the vice president
is clearly not doing that and democrats
didn't take him up on that but i think
when you when you look at what's
happening here they're flying people
middle night hoping that people don't
notice even though they can see what's
happening what's going on here is the
the american taxpayer is subsidizing
human trafficking they are finishing the
final leg of human trafficking so what
happens is in south america say you're
from el salvador someone paid for an
unaccompanied minor to get taken to the
border
hhs gets them after being processed
through border patrol and then the
american taxpayer is footing the bill
for these people to be put on planes and
flown all over the country i'm not
really sure why if we can fly them from
the border to new york why we can't find
them from the border to el salvador or
back to where they came from to reunite
you to reunite them with their families
there apparently that's not on the table
but lawmakers been sounding the alarm on
this for long for for months they were
flying through tennessee and senator
marsha blackburn said what are you guys
doing you're secretly putting these
flights into our communities which by
the way federal government's not giving
the resources to handle these people and
they lied about it and now that they've
been caught they're trying to grapple
with whether it's in the middle of the
night or at four in the morning
jesse anything i'm doing it for in the
morning can't be good that's exactly my
point
anybody that does something in the
middle of the night in secret unless
they're garbage men they're not proud of
that yes you're not proud of that no
one's proud of what you're doing in
secret in the middle of the night joe
knows he's wrong he knows he's wrong he
feels guilty about it and that's why
he's hiding this like a coward
own it make your case to the american
people said this is what we're doing
this is the policy and we're going to do
it in daylight but he won't because he
can't because he knows if people know
about this policy the country is going
to be appalled and that's why no one
besides fox will report this
if you
ask jen saki about this and she doesn't
give you an answer here are some
follow-up questions
you can't vet sponsors and relatives
after what you did in afghanistan
we didn't even get our guys out of
afghanistan we couldn't even vet an army
after 20 years and now you know that
these sponsors are vetted you know these
are the real parents
come on you don't know that
this is taxpayer-funded human
trafficking who are these people that
they're giving them to who are these
agencies that are getting these fat
federal contracts to receive these
teenagers
who are they she can't answer that
question and she needs to be asked that
question americans can't get even get on
flights because they're being canceled
because of vax mandates but you're going
to give illegals free flights free food
he's advertising to the entire western
hemisphere cross our border if you're
under 18. we're going to fly to miami
we're going to fly you to new york this
is crazy
this is crazy i don't think i don't
think things are right up there i just
went this is wrong it's still weird the
timing why it doesn't have to be at 4am
why is it why do you think yeah he's not
even telling the governors he's doing
this yeah well and it's very he doesn't
want anybody to know if you see these
people in the airport they're all
wearing the same thing they'll have the
same paperwork and they have a handler
and they're not allowed to talk to
anybody so it's a very organized effort
and someone's getting paid yeah it's
terrible but we shouldn't let's not
speculate too much but i would agree
with the premise this is not the way to
do this yeah all right up next democrats
forced to scale back their plans on the
irs snooping around in your bank